OK, so let's begin today with this story about two people. These are two people with two very different perspectives on the world. And the one thing these two people have in common, the only thing that connects them, is a can of olives that one of them sends to the other. Diane Wu, one of the producers of our show, she looked into this. Hey, Diane.
好的，我们今天先从这两个人的故事讲起。这两个人看待世界的角度截然不同。他们之间唯一的共同点，也是唯一的联系，就是其中一人寄给另一人的一罐橄榄。我们节目的制作人之一黛安·吴深入调查了这件事。嘿，黛安。
Hello, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
So?
所以呢？
So the first person in the story is named Caroline. She was a year out of college when this package arrived to her parents' house, a place she hadn't lived for many years. Her mom texted her.
故事里的第一个人叫卡罗琳。她大学毕业一年后，这个包裹寄到了她父母家，那是她很多年没住过的地方。她妈妈给她发了条短信。
What do you want me to do with this box from Walmart.com?
你从Walmart.com买的这个箱子，你想让我怎么处理？
Which was weird because Caroline hadn't ordered anything from Walmart, like ever, so she just texted her mom back to say, well, just open it up and see what's inside.
这很奇怪，因为卡罗琳从来没在沃尔玛买过东西，一次都没有。所以她回短信给妈妈，说，好吧，打开看看里面有什么。
And then she texts me that it's a can of black olives. It's just like this can of black olives and an empty box. No note, no nothing.
然后她给我发短信说是一罐黑橄榄。就只有一罐黑橄榄和一个空箱子。没有字条，什么都没有。
So Caroline starts texting her friends and asks them, did you send me these olives? Is there, like, an olive inside joke that we have that I forgot about?
于是卡罗琳开始给朋友发短信问他们：是你寄给我这些橄榄的吗？我们之间是不是有什么我忘了的关于橄榄的梗？
And people are like, I don't know what you're talking about. Like, I didn't send you any olives.
大家说：不知道你在说什么。我没给你寄橄榄。
One of her friends wrote, oh, the classic oliving. So Caroline then goes to urbandictionary.com and types in "oliving." Nothing comes up.
其中一个朋友写道：噢，经典的“橄榄陷阱”。于是卡罗琳去urbandictionary.com查了“oliving”（橄榄陷阱）。结果什么也没查到。
So her friend was kidding?
所以她朋友是在开玩笑？
Yeah. Caroline thinks, OK, maybe Walmart just made a mistake. This was a random computer glitch. Or maybe her friends were lying and one of them did send it. So she calls Walmart. There's no receipt but the order number was on the box.
是的。卡罗琳心想，好吧，也许是沃尔玛弄错了。这只是个随机的电脑故障。或者可能是朋友在撒谎，其中一个确实寄了。于是她给沃尔玛打了电话。箱子上没有收据，但有订单号。
And?
然后呢？
And they told her it was not a random computer glitch. There was a person who ordered it and sent it to her, like a real person, and he's the other person in the story.
他们告诉她，这并不是随机的电脑故障。确实有个人订购并寄给了她，是个真实的人，他就是这个故事里的另一个人。
And they gave me the name. They said it was this guy named Christopher Fouts, and I don't know anyone by that name.
他们给了我名字。说是一个叫克里斯托弗·福茨的人，我不认识任何叫这个名字的人。
She thinks, why would a total stranger send me a can of olives? So she Google's Christopher Fouts, looks for him on Facebook, but she can't figure out who he is.
她心想，为什么一个素不相识的人要寄给我一罐橄榄？于是她在谷歌上搜索克里斯托弗·福茨，在Facebook上找他，但搞不清他是谁。
Who do you think Christopher Fouts is? How do you imagine him?
你觉得克里斯托弗·福茨是什么样的人？你怎么想象他？
I imagine that maybe he has, like-- this is a very specific thing that I'm imagining.
我想象他可能……我脑子里的画面非常具体。
Go for it.
说说看。
OK, so I imagine that, I don't know, he has a day-to-day office job where he comes in to the cubicle every day, and grinds away. And so on the side, he likes to pull these pranks and whatnot.
好吧，我想象他是一个每天做着朝九晚五办公室工作的人，每天坐在隔间里，忙忙碌碌。所以闲暇时，他喜欢搞点这种恶作剧之类的。
Caroline really liked the whole idea that there was this stranger out there somewhere in the world sending random packages to people, just to surprise them.
卡罗琳很喜欢这个想法：世界上某个地方有个陌生人，为了给人们惊喜而随机寄送包裹。
I think it means there's hope, you know? If some random person is just going to send you olives to make you smile when you open up-- you know?
我觉得这意味着希望，你懂吗？如果有个陌生人只是为了让你在打开包裹时微笑，就给你寄橄榄——你懂吧？
OK, so after that conversation, you set out to find Christopher Fouts, right?
好的，那次谈话后，你就出发去找克里斯托弗·福茨了，对吧？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
To ask him why he sent her the olives. Was it hard to find him?
去问他为什么给卡罗琳寄橄榄。找他难吗？
It was a little bit hard. He isn't easily Google-able. I had to write him a letter, like in the mail. And it got forwarded to Germany, because that's where he lives now. So a couple weeks after I started looking for him, he sent me back an email.
有点难。他很难通过谷歌搜索到。我不得不给他写了一封信，通过邮寄。信被转寄到了德国，因为他现在住在那儿。所以在我开始找他几周后，他给我回了一封邮件。
So did you tell him Caroline's theory that he's out there sending random stuff to strangers to make them smile?
那你告诉他卡罗琳的理论了吗？就是他寄这些随机的东西给陌生人是为了让他们微笑？
I did. I ran that by him. And he told me--
我说了。我把这个理论告诉了他。他告诉我说——
That was not my motivation whatsoever.
那根本就不是我的动机。
So it turns out Christopher Fouts sells stuff on Amazon as a side gig. He runs the whole operation out of his basement. He sells household goods. And Caroline was one of his customers.
结果发现克里斯托弗·福茨是个兼职的亚马逊卖家。他在地下室经营整个生意。他卖家居用品。卡罗琳是他的客户之一。
Miss Caroline had placed an order on December 30th for a 12 piece dining ware set.
卡罗琳小姐在12月30日订购了一套12件套的餐具。
But when he went to his basement to send the dining ware set to her, he found out he didn't have it in stock. So Christopher went online and bought it from Walmart, had them send it to her at the address she gave, which was her parents' house. But there was a snag.
但当他去地下室准备把这套餐具寄给她时，发现没货了。于是克里斯托弗上网在沃尔玛买了这套餐具，让沃尔玛直接寄到她提供的地址，也就是她父母家。但有个小麻烦。
The dinner ware set was below Walmart's threshold for free shipping.
这套餐具的价格未达到沃尔玛免邮的门槛。
Enter the star of our show, the can of olives.
这时我们节目的主角出场了：那罐橄榄。
Adding the can of black olives put the order at above the threshold for the free shipping.
加上那罐黑橄榄，订单总额就超过了免邮门槛。
How much did he save?
他省了多少钱？
$3.70, by adding the olives.
通过加那罐橄榄，他省了3.70美元。
Is there any part of you, when you did this, that thought about Caroline opening the box and getting the olives?
你做这件事的时候，有没有哪怕一丁点想到卡罗琳打开箱子拿到橄榄时的心情？
No, actually. I was just thinking about minimizing my losses on this order.
没有，事实上。我只是在想如何把这笔订单的损失降到最低。
So basically she has thought about him a lot. He has never given her any thought at all. And the answer to Caroline's question about where her olives came from? It is the least romantic answer you could possibly come up with.
所以基本情况是，她经常想到他，而他从来没想过她。至于卡罗琳的问题——她的橄榄是从哪儿来的，答案可能是你能想到的最不浪漫的答案。
Like, it's less romantic than just a random computer glitch. A guy trying to save $3.70 in shipping costs. So Diane and I called Caroline, and we explained how Christopher Fouts saw their whole transaction. Her reaction to this, I think, cut to the heart of the matter succinctly.
甚至比随机的电脑故障还不浪漫。一个试图省下3.70美元运费的男人。于是我和黛安给卡罗琳打了电话，解释了克里斯托弗·福茨是如何看待他们整个交易的。我觉得她对此的反应一针见血。
I think we're just very different people.
我想我们确实是两类不同的人。
True enough. And the way you see a can of olives depends on your perspective about things in general. Like, do you choose to see life as an adventure or do you see it as a guy trying to reduce shipping costs? Caroline, of course, knows where she stands.
确实如此。你看待一罐橄榄的方式取决于你对事物的整体看法。比如，你选择把生活看作一场冒险，还是看作一个男人试图减少运费？卡罗琳当然知道自己的立场。
Life's an adventure. I mean-- yeah, it's like-- I feel like if I had the mentality that life was a guy reducing his shipping costs, that would be just so sad.
生活是一场冒险。我的意思是——是的，我觉得如果我抱着“生活就是一个男人在试图节省运费”的心态，那该有多可悲。
I have to say, I'm with you. I also think life is an adventure, but I do acknowledge the stunning amount of information that we get all the time, letting us know that a lot of it is a guy reducing his shipping cost.
不得不说，我和你一样。我也认为生活是一场冒险，但我确实意识到我们一直在接收大量的信息，告诉我们很多事情只是一个男人在省运费而已。
Yes. Most of the data points are a guy reducing his shipping cost, I would say.
是的。我想说，大多数数据点都是一个男人在节省运费。
Well, today on our radio show we meet some people who are going into remarkable situations, and I mean true adventures. We have a space explorer who went to the moon, a professional basketball player, people embracing big dreams. Except all these people are Christopher's. They are not Caroline's.
好吧，今天在我们的电台节目中，我们将见到一些正身处非凡处境的人，我是说真正的冒险。我们有一位去过月球的太空探险家、一名职业篮球运动员，还有拥抱远大梦想的人。但所有这些人都是“克里斯托弗式”的。他们不是“卡罗琳式”的。
They are all about keeping shipping costs low. They are practical people in situations so many of us would find deeply thrilling. How they managed to be who they are in the face of spectacular wonder and the vast unknown-- from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
他们关心的全是如何降低运输成本。他们是务实的人，身处我们许多人会觉得非常惊心动魄的环境中。面对壮丽的奇观和广阔的未知，他们是如何维持自我的——这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1-- "So Over the Moon." So a man takes a trip to a place that a lot of people dream of going. The food's not the best, but the scenery is pretty great. Anyway, the experience of it for him was not what you usually hear. David Kestenbaum tells the story.
第一幕——“飞跃月球”。一个人去了一个许多人梦想去的地方。那里的食物不是最好的，但风景相当不错。无论如何，对他来说，那次经历并不是你通常听到的那样。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆讲述了这个故事。
I found out about this guy entirely by accident. I was watching this short documentary that just came out about the Apollo 8 mission. This is the 50th anniversary.
我完全是偶然发现这个人的。我当时正在看一部刚上映的关于阿波罗8号任务的短纪录片。这是50周年纪念。
It was a beautiful film with all this footage from the launch and from space. So I reached out to the filmmaker, Emmanuel Vaughan-Lee, thinking maybe we could do some version of it here on the radio. Maybe we'd do a show about space.
那是一部精美的影片，有所有来自发射和太空的镜头。所以我联系了制片人伊曼纽尔·沃恩-李，心想也许我们可以在电台上做个版本。也许我们可以做一期关于太空的节目。
And it turns out Emmanuel had done these very long, multi-day interviews with each of the three astronauts. He sent me raw recordings. And listening through, I heard something I was not expecting at all.
结果发现伊曼纽尔对三名宇航员中的每一位都做了非常长的、为期数天的采访。他把原始录音发给了我。听着听着，我听到了一些我完全没预料到的内容。
One of the astronauts, Frank Borman, was saying things I had just never heard an astronaut say. Like this--
其中一名宇航员，弗兰克·博尔曼，在说一些我从未听过宇航员说的话。就像这样——
Space science fiction still bores me. I've never seen-- what's the name of that-- that very popular--
科幻太空小说仍然让我感到无聊。我从来没看过——那部叫什么来着——非常受欢迎的那部——
2001?
《2001太空漫游》？
Yeah, all that crap. I've never seen any of that.
是的，所有那些废话。我从来没看过那些。
Emmanuel, the filmmaker, also seemed amused. He pressed on. What about when you were a kid?
制片人伊曼纽尔似乎也被逗乐了。他继续追问。那你小时候呢？
And what about the stars or astronomy?
那你对星星或天文学感兴趣吗？
No.
没有。
None of that?
一点都没有？
Airplanes.
飞机。
Airplanes, and airplanes only.
只有飞机，还是飞机。
Wow. Wow.
哇。哇。
And a certain particular girl.
还有一个特别的女孩。
Susan.
苏珊。
Yeah. So--
是的。所以——
Susan is Borman's wife. They fell in love in high school. Borman was game to answer any question Emmanuel put to him, though he particularly seemed to like the ones he could easily dispatch answers to, like a little problem he had solved.
苏珊是博尔曼的妻子。他们高中时相爱。博尔曼很乐意回答伊曼纽尔提出的任何问题，尽管他似乎特别喜欢那些能轻松给出答案的问题，就像他解决的一个小问题。
In 1945--
在1945年——
He was very matter of fact. When Emanuel asked if being in the cramped spaceship was like being in a submarine, Borman said, "I don't know. I've never been in a submarine." My sense reading press accounts from back in the day is that Borman wasn't this blunt about it all back in the '60s, when astronauts were supposed to be playing the part of America's heroes. But now, time has passed. He's 90 years old. He says he doesn't give a damn.
他非常实事求是。当伊曼纽尔问呆在狭窄的飞船里是否像呆在潜水艇里时，博尔曼说：“我不知道。我从没呆过潜水艇里。”我读过当年的新闻报道，感觉博尔曼在60年代并没有这么直白，当时宇航员们被要求扮演美国英雄的角色。但现在，时代变了。他90岁了。他说他根本不在乎。
I never knowingly altered it, but it was very difficult for me to be as candid now, I think, as I was then-- I just didn't cover some things as in-depth as you're doing here today.
我从未故意改口，但我认为现在要我像当时那样坦诚非常困难——我只是没有像今天这样深入地谈论某些事情。
And when you have been this candid and honest as you are now, what's been people's reactions?
当你像现在这样坦诚时，人们的反应如何？
I haven't had any reaction, because I'm just being it with you. [LAUGHS]
我没收到任何反应，因为我只是在和你交谈。[笑]
When I was a science reporter, I covered NASA for years. So I've interviewed my share of astronauts. But I always felt like I wasn't really getting it what it was like to be in space.
我当科学记者时，报道过美国国家航空航天局（NASA）很多年。所以我采访过不少宇航员。但我总觉得我并没有真正体会到在太空中的感受。
Don't get me wrong. They were polite and smart. But there was a sameness to it all. They talk about how amazing it was to be weightless, about how it was humankind's destiny to leave the planet and explore.
别误会。他们很有礼貌也很聪明。但这一切都有点雷同。他们谈论失重是多么神奇，谈论离开地球探索是人类的命运。
But I always felt like of course they'd say that. They want to get picked by their bosses to go into space again, and it's the polite thing to say. It's what people want to hear. And I imagine it's what they felt. After all, that is exactly the kind of person who ends up becoming an astronaut.
但我总觉得他们当然会那样说。他们想被老板选中再次进入太空，而且这是得体的说法。这是人们想听到的。而且我想这也是他们的感受。毕竟，这正是那种最终会成为宇航员的人。
I've always wondered what someone else might make of going up there, experiencing the vastness of the universe and coming home again. Borman seemed different. He was the astronaut I had always wanted to hear from.
我一直好奇其他人如果去那里，体验宇宙的广阔并回到家，会有什么想法。博尔曼看起来很不一样。他是我一直想采访的那种宇航员。
Borman lives in Billings, Montana. He agreed to block out a couple of hours so we could talk. I flew out there. We met in the lobby of the hotel with no real plan for how to recognize each other.
博尔曼住在蒙大拿州的比林斯。他同意腾出几个小时让我们谈谈。我飞到了那里。我们在酒店大堂见面，对于如何认出对方，我们没有具体的计划。
There were a lot of retirees around, and I kept wondering is that the guy who's been to outer space? Maybe that guy? We eventually found each other.
周围有很多退休人员，我一直在想：那是那个去过外太空的人吗？也许是那个人？最终我们找到了彼此。
He was walking slowly, shirt tucked in. I'd read that when he was an astronaut they'd had to spend $45,000 to make a special helmet for him because his head was larger than others. But I don't know, it seemed normal to me.
他走得很慢，衬衫扎在裤子里。我读过他当宇航员时，他们不得不花4.5万美元为他做一个特殊的头盔，因为他的头比别人大。但我不知道，我觉得挺正常的。
We sat down in a little conference room. I'd half wondered if we should use our time together to watch 2001-- A Space Odyssey. I thought if he actually saw it, he might like it. But it's a long film. I went with something shorter.
我们在一个小会议室里坐下。我曾半开玩笑地想，我们是否应该利用在一起的时间看一遍《2001太空漫游》。我想如果他真的看了，他可能会喜欢。但那是一部很长的电影。我选了一部短点的。
Can I show you something and see if it speaks to you at all?
我可以给你看点东西，看看它是否触动你吗？
Star Trek. Yeah, that's what I was-- I've never seen that.
《星际迷航》。是的，我当时——我从没看过那个。
Space, the final frontier. These are the voyages of the Starship Enterprise--
太空，最后的边境。这是星际飞船“企业号”的航行——
I looked at Borman as he watched, but I couldn't read his expression.
我看着博尔曼观看时，但读不出他的表情。
--to seek out new life and new civilizations, to boldly go where no one has gone before.
——去寻找新的生命和新的文明，勇敢地前往无人涉足的地方。
Nonsense to me. I-- it doesn't interest me. I'm sorry.
对我来说是废话。我——它不吸引我。我很抱歉。
To go where no man has gone before, that doesn't do anything for you?
去无人涉足的地方，这对你一点意义都没有吗？
No.
没有。
But you did it.
但你做到了。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
He really did. When Borman became an astronaut, only eight people had ever been into space. Apollo 8-- the mission he was commander of-- it was the very first time humans had ever left Earth's orbit.
他确实做到了。博尔曼成为宇航员时，只有8个人去过太空。阿波罗8号——他担任指挥官的任务——这是人类第一次离开地球轨道。
Borman and the two other crew members in this tiny spacecraft went all the way to the moon. They didn't land. It was kind of a dry run for the moon landing.
博尔曼和另外两名船员乘坐这个小飞船一直飞到了月球。他们没有着陆。这算是登月计划的一次彩排。
But in some ways, it actually seems more exciting to me and terrifying. It was the first time anyone had gone that far from the earth, really ventured out into space, seeing the moon so close up. This other celestial body right there, outside the window. He was 40 years old.
但在某些方面，这对我来说实际上更令人兴奋和恐怖。这是第一次有人离地球那么远，真正冒险进入太空，近距离观察月球。就在窗外，这颗天体。他当时40岁。
How did Borman-- the guy who didn't really care about space-- end up being one of the first people to go to the moon? It's true. This was the beginning of the space program, and a lot of the early astronauts were test pilots.
博尔曼这个对太空并不怎么在乎的人，怎么会成为第一批去月球的人呢？事实是，这是太空计划的初期，很多早期宇航员都是试飞员。
But still, the other two guys Borman flew with-- they were the type of people who might have gone to space camp as kids. If space camp had existed back then.
但即便如此，和博尔曼一起飞行的另外两个家伙——他们是那种小时候可能会去参加太空营的人。如果当时有太空营的话。
One of them, Bill Anders, loved geology. As a kid, he had decided he wanted to own a piece of every rock in the world. The other, Jim Lovell, while in high school, had tried to build a model rocket, one powered by liquid oxygen.
其中一个，比尔·安德斯，热爱地质学。小时候，他决定要拥有世界上每一块岩石。另一个，吉姆·洛弗尔，在高中时曾试图制造一个模型火箭，由液氧驱动。
Lovell was mesmerized by space and exploration, and wanted desperately to explore the moon. I was there because it was a battle in the Cold War. I wanted to participate in this American adventure of beating the Soviets. But that's the only thing that motivated me-- beat the damn Russians.
洛弗尔被太空和探索迷住了，非常渴望探索月球。我当时在那里是因为那是冷战的一场战争。我想参与这场击败苏联的美国冒险。但这就是唯一激励我的动力——击败那些该死的俄国人。
I've always known we were in a race to beat the Russians, but I didn't realize how intense it could have felt back then. The Russians had launched the first satellite, Sputnik. They were also the first to put a man in space, the first to put a woman in space.
我一直知道我们在一场击败俄国人的竞赛中，但我没意识到当时那种感觉有多强烈。俄国人发射了第一颗卫星，斯普特尼克号。他们也是第一个将男人送入太空、第一个将女人送入太空的国家。
The Russians did the first spacewalk. They landed a probe on the moon before we did. The US always seemed a step behind. As Borman saw it, a freedom loving democracy was being beaten by a dictatorship. And whoever put a person on the moon first, that was going to be in the history books forever.
俄国人完成了第一次太空行走。他们比我们更早让探测器在月球着陆。美国看起来总是落后一步。博尔曼认为，一个爱好自由的民主国家正在被独裁统治击败。而谁先让人类登上月球，谁就会永远载入史册。
Borman was an Air Force pilot who'd gone to West Point. He had a reputation for being blunt, and also kind of serious. He didn't like anyone messing around.
博尔曼是一名曾就读西点军校的空军飞行员。他以直言不讳著称，也有点严肃。他不喜欢任何人胡闹。
He'd never been in battle, but he thought this is where the real fight is now. So he applied to be an astronaut. The psychiatrist who evaluated him later said Borman was the least complicated man he had ever met.
他从没上过战场，但他认为这是真正的战斗。所以他申请成为宇航员。后来评估他的心理医生说，博尔曼是他见过最简单的人。
What do you think he meant by that?
你觉得他是什么意思？
I don't-- I have no idea. I have no idea. I don't-- whether I'm complicated or uncomplicated.
我不知道——我毫无头绪。我不知道——我不知道我是复杂还是简单。
What would Susan say?
苏珊会怎么说？
Susan says this. I was the most uncomplicated man she ever knew.
苏珊是这么说的：我是她认识的最简单的人。
Are you a romantic person?
你是一个浪漫的人吗？
I think in some ways I am. I get emotional at good movies at times, and things like that.
我觉得在某些方面我是。我有时会被好的电影感动，诸如此类。
What movies do you watch?
你看什么电影？
Probably the best movie that I've ever seen is Casablanca. I love Casablanca.
可能我见过的最好的电影是《卡萨布兰卡》。我喜欢《卡萨布兰卡》。
Why do you like Casablanca?
你为什么喜欢《卡萨布兰卡》？
Casablanca was a wonderful wartime story of the recognition that a good cause is more important than the human being relationship.
《卡萨布兰卡》是一部美妙的战时故事，体现了一种认识：崇高的事业比人类关系更重要。
Oh.
哦。
Win the war and lose the woman was what that was all about.
赢得战争而失去女人，这才是整个故事的重点。
That's the opposite of romantic.
这恰恰是不浪漫的。
No, it's very romantic.
不，这非常浪漫。
I asked Borman to walk me through the mission, what it was like for him at each stage.
我请博尔曼带我梳理一遍任务过程，他在每个阶段的感受。
T-minus seven minutes, 30 seconds--
倒计时七分三十秒——
On the morning of the Apollo 8 launch, December 21, 1968, Borman and the two other astronauts sat atop the Saturn 5 rocket, which had only been tested twice, not with anyone on it. The Apollo 1 had caught fire on the launch pad, killing three astronauts. Borman's left hand was on an abort switch.
1968年12月21日阿波罗8号发射的早晨，博尔曼和另外两名宇航员坐在土星5号火箭顶端，该火箭只测试过两次，且无人乘坐。阿波罗1号曾在发射台上起火，导致三名宇航员死亡。博尔曼的左手放在中止开关上。
He told me he wasn't scared. But Susan, his wife-- she was. She and their two kids had come to watch the other time Borman had gone into space for the Gemini 7 launch. But this rocket, the Saturn 5 rocket, was way, way, way bigger-- 36 stories high. So with this one, they didn't come.
他告诉我他不害怕。但他的妻子苏珊——她害怕。当博尔曼另一次进入太空执行双子座7号发射任务时，她和两个孩子曾来观看。但这个火箭，土星5号火箭，要大得多得多得多——有36层楼高。所以这次，他们没来。
Rockets-- you know, it's a very loud and frightening thing. And to have your husband and father in the nose of the thing is-- I think it was difficult for them.
火箭——你知道，这东西声音非常大，非常吓人。而你的丈夫和父亲就在这东西的顶端——我觉得对他们来说很难。
--and the pressure's still building up--
——压力还在增加——
She said it was. That's why she stayed home.
她说确实如此。这就是为什么她待在家里。
--45 seconds. Final reports coming from Frank Borman at this time.
——45秒。目前来自弗兰克·博尔曼的最终报告。
I wasn't going to play you the 5, 4, 3, 2, 1 tape, but then I listened back to it. It's pretty good. It's like you can hear how big the thing is.
我本来不想给你播放那段5、4、3、2、1的录音，但后来我回听了一下。挺不错的。听起来你就能感受到这玩意儿有多大。
One of the astronauts said it felt like being a rat in the jaws of a big terrier.
其中一名宇航员说感觉就像被困在大型梗犬口中的老鼠。
We have ignition sequence start. The engines are on. 4, 3, 2, 1, 0-- we have connect. We have--
我们有点火序列启动。引擎开启。4、3、2、1、0——我们连接上了。我们——
Lift off. The clock is running.
点火升空。计时开始。
We have lift off.
我们点火升空了。
[INAUDIBLE] looking good.
[听不清] 看起来不错。
OK, so after the launch-- and please, don't feel compelled to answer yes to any of these questions, you know.
好的，发射之后——请不要觉得必须对这些问题回答“是”，你知道的。
Oh, I won't. I'mma tell you the truth. OK.
哦，我不会。我会告诉你实话。好的。
Was it cool to float around weightless?
失重漂浮的感觉酷吗？
[LAUGHS] No.
[笑] 不。
I think everyone thinks it would be amazing to be weightless and floating.
我想每个人都认为失重和漂浮会很神奇。
He said his main observation about being in zero g was just the obvious thing. When you let go of something in midair, it would stay there.
他说他关于零重力的主要观察只是显而易见的事情。当你把东西在半空中放开时，它就会待在那里。
Turn loose of this and it would stay there. Except when turning loose of it, you'd probably impart a little motion to it so it would float around. But--
放手，它就留在那里。除非你在放手时可能给它一点力，让它漂来漂去。但是——
Was that interesting to observe?
观察那个有趣吗？
Maybe for the first 30 seconds, then it became accepted.
也许前30秒有趣，然后就习以为常了。
I think of explorers as the people who push into new territory, bring back exotic experiences to the rest of us in the ordinary world. But I like the idea the opposite might also be true. That after a while somewhere new, it starts to feel familiar, even outer space.
我认为探险家是那些推动进入新领域，为我们在平凡世界中的其他人带回异国体验的人。但我喜欢相反的情况也可能成立的想法。就是在某个新地方待久了，它就开始变得熟悉，甚至是外太空。
[INAUDIBLE] coming up on 20 seconds to ignition.
[听不清] 距离点火还有20秒。
After they reached orbit, Borman and the two others fired the rocket engine again and did what had never been done before. They headed away from the safety of the planet, and out toward the moon. It was going to take them two days to get there. Two days in the middle of nothingness.
进入轨道后，博尔曼和另外两人再次启动火箭引擎，完成了前所未有的创举。他们离开了行星的安全地带，朝着月球飞去。到达那里需要两天时间。在虚无中度过两天。
Borman says interviewers always ask if it felt lonely. He feels like everyone wants him to say yes. But the answer was no.
博尔曼说采访者总是问是否感到孤独。他觉得每个人都想让他说是。但答案是否定的。
I can't tell if you're the best person or the worst person to have gone to the moon, in terms of describing what it's like.
我看不出你是去过月球的最佳人选还是最差人选，就描述那种感受而言。
I'm probably the worst.
我可能是最差的。
Did you say, at some point, they should have sent a poet?
你有没有在某个时候说他们应该派个诗人去？
No, I didn't-- if I did, I didn't-- the last thing I would have wanted on our crew was a poet. [LAUGHS]
没有，我没——如果我说了，我没——我最不想要的就是我们的机组里有一个诗人。[笑]
The trip seemed like it was this weird combination of something intense and romantic and otherworldly, but also a little like a long car ride. At one point in the transcripts, one of them says, "I'm warm now. How about you?" Borman says. "I'm hot." The other guy says, "Man, I'm still cold."
这次旅行看起来既激烈、浪漫又超凡脱俗，但也有点像长途乘车。在录音稿中，有一次其中一个人说：“我现在暖和了。你呢？”博尔曼说：“我热。”另一个人说：“天哪，我还冷着呢。”
And this happens on long car rides. People sometimes get sick. In this case, it was Borman.
长途乘车时也会发生这种情况。人们有时会感到不适。在这种情况下，是博尔曼。
How does throwing up work in space?
呕吐在太空中是怎么处理的？
Same as it does on Earth. Uncomfortable and I tried to capture it in a disposal bag, but I didn't get all of it.
和在地球上一样。不舒服，我试图用废弃袋接住它，但我没接住全部。
Still I just could not swallow the idea that none of this had moved him. You're in space going over 20,000 miles an hour, stars everywhere. The first people to really leave the Earth.
尽管如此，我还是无法接受这一切对他没有任何触动。你在以每小时超过20,000英里的速度在太空中穿行，到处都是星星。第一批真正离开地球的人。
[INAUDIBLE] is coming to you approximately half-way between the moon and the Earth. We've been 31 hours, about 20 minutes into the flight, we have about less than 40 hours left to go to the moon.
[听不清] 大约在月球和地球之间飞行。我们已经飞行了31小时20分钟，离月球还有不到40小时。
Borman says there was really just one moment where he felt something stir in his uncomplicated self. It happened while they were circling the moon, which as a destination, he says, did not look like a place you would ever want to live or work.
博尔曼说确实有一个时刻，他感到自己简单的内心有所波动。那是当他们环绕月球时，他说月球作为目的地，看起来不像一个你想居住或工作的地方。
Oh, devastation. Meteor craters, no color at all. Just different shades of gray.
噢，是一片荒芜。陨石坑，根本没有颜色。只有不同深浅的灰色。
And then peering out the small windows, over the gray landscape of the moon, they saw something coming up over the horizon. It was the earth, and it was beautiful. This blue and white marble, the only thing that had any color. Here's how he described it to Emmanuel, the filmmaker.
然后透过小窗户，俯瞰月球灰色的景观，他们看到地平线上出现了什么东西。那是地球，它很美。这颗蓝白相间的球体，唯一有颜色的东西。他是这样向制片人伊曼纽尔描述的。
It's 240,000 miles away. It was small enough you could cover it with your thumbnail. The dearest things in life that were back on the Earth-- my family, my wife, my parents. They were still alive then. That was, for me, the high point of the flight from an emotional standpoint.
它在24万英里之外。它小到可以用大拇指盖住。生命中最珍贵的东西都在地球上——我的家人、我的妻子、我的父母。他们当时还活着。从情感角度来看，那是我这次飞行的高光时刻。
It's like the high point of being in space was the Earth.
感觉在太空中最高光的时刻竟然是地球。
The contrast between our memories of the Earth and the color on the Earth, and the totally bleak and dead moon was striking.
我们对地球的记忆和地球上的颜色，与完全荒凉死寂的月球之间的对比太震撼了。
They'd been taking hundreds of photos of the surface of the moon, because, you know, no one had ever been there. NASA wanted to pick out a future landing site.
他们一直在拍摄数百张月球表面的照片，因为你知道，从来没有人去过那里。美国国家航空航天局想选定未来的着陆点。
They took so many photos of the moon that Bill Anders, the astronaut who was doing it, said it got boring. There was nothing in the mission plan to take pictures of the Earth. It's like it hadn't even occurred to anyone it might look interesting.
他们拍了太多月球照片，以至于负责拍摄的宇航员比尔·安德斯说这变得很无聊。任务计划中没有拍地球的内容。好像甚至没人想到它看起来会很有趣。
But Borman and the crew, when they saw the Earth rising over the moon, they were like, whoa, that is a photo. There's actually audio of this moment.
但当博尔曼和机组人员看到地球在月球上方升起时，他们惊呆了，说：哇，那真是一幅美照。其实有那个时刻的音频。
Oh, my god. Look at that picture over there. There's the Earth coming up. Wow, that's pretty!
天哪。看那张照片。地球升起来了。哇，太美了！
Hey, don't take that. It's not scheduled.
嘿，别拍那个。不在计划内。
That's Borman there, saying, don't take that. It's not scheduled. He was joking.
那是博尔曼在说：别拍那个。不在计划内。他在开玩笑。
Hand me a roll of color quick, would you?
快给我一卷彩色胶卷，好吗？
Oh, man this [INAUDIBLE].
哦，天哪，这[听不清]。
It ended up being one of the most famous photos of all time. If you Google "Earth rise," you'd be like, oh, yeah. That one.
这最终成了史上最著名的照片之一。如果你在谷歌上搜索“地出”，你会说：噢，是的。就是那张。
It's like the first selfie of us all, the whole planet, and it's remarkable. It's exactly other worldly. Humans have been watching the moon rise from the earth for hundreds of thousands of years. This was the first time someone had seen the reverse-- us, our planet, rising over the moon's horizon.
这就像是我们全人类的第一个自拍，整个行星，非常非凡。它确实是超凡脱俗的。人类几十万年来一直在地球上观看月升。这是第一次有人看到反过来的一幕——我们，我们的地球，在月球地平线上升起。
The other thing that strikes me about this photo is just how truly dark space can get. Only half the Earth is lit up. The other half is in complete blackness, like it's been consumed by something. I asked Borman if that was just the exposure of the photo. He said no, it's exactly how it looked.
关于这张照片，另一件让我震惊的事是太空竟然能如此黑暗。地球只有一半被照亮。另一半处于完全的黑暗中，就像被什么东西吞噬了一样。我问博尔曼那是不是曝光造成的。他说不，它看起来确实就是那样。
It took a couple of days for Borman and the others to travel a quarter of a million miles back here. It was mostly uneventful. At some point, Jim Lovell punched some wrong buttons on the computer, which reset the guidance system.
博尔曼和其他人花了几天时间才走完这25万英里回到这里。大部分时间都很平静。有一次，吉姆·洛弗尔在电脑上按错了按钮，重置了制导系统。
The spacecraft had no idea where it was. Lovell had to measure the position of stars by hand, just like sailors used to do at sea. They eventually splashed down in the ocean.
飞船根本不知道它在哪里。洛弗尔不得不像水手在海上那样，用手测量星星的位置。他们最终在海洋中溅落。
They were elated. The mission was over. Everything had worked. Borman says it felt like he imagines winning the World Series might.
他们欣喜若狂。任务结束了。一切都运行正常。博尔曼说感觉就像他想象中赢得世界大赛那样。
He had a quick phone call from the president while on board an aircraft carrier. And then he went home to his kids and his wife, Susan.
在航空母舰上时，他接到了总统的快速电话。然后他回家见他的孩子和妻子苏珊。
How did you describe the mission to her? Like, what you'd seen. I mean, you'd just been on this incredible--
你是怎么向她描述这次任务的？比如，你看到的东西。我的意思是，你刚刚经历了一次不可思议的——
I really didn't talk about it very much. As a matter of fact, I can't remember talking to her at all about it.
我真的没怎么谈论它。事实上，我不记得我和她谈论过它。
You don't remember saying, you won't believe what the moon looks like. I was up there?
你不记得说：你不会相信月球看起来是什么样的。我曾在那上面？
No, we didn't talk a lot about it. No.
不，我们没谈论太多。不。
Why not?
为什么不？
It was more important to see the boys and see her. And what have you be doing? We're back. It was a wonderful time of reunion and emotion, and the last thing from my mind was to tell them what the moon looked like.
去见孩子们见她更重要。你在做些什么？我们回来了。那是一段团聚和情感的美好时光，我脑子里想的最少的事情就是告诉他们月球看起来是什么样子。
Didn't they want to know?
他们不想知道吗？
No. Nobody asked. [LAUGHS]
不。没人问。[笑]
What do you think you did talk about?
你觉得你们谈论了什么？
How glad I was to be home, how glad they were to have me back, and how the boys are doing in school, and why the dog's dish was still full. We got right back to the nitty-gritty's.
我回家有多高兴，他们有我回来有多高兴，孩子们在学校的表现，为什么狗碗还是满的。我们直接回到了正题。
Just seven months later, Buzz Aldrin and Neil Armstrong set foot on the moon. The Russians gave up, which for Borman had been the point of the whole thing. So he did something that today seems kind of amazing. He quit. He left the job so many kids dream about.
仅仅七个月后，巴兹·奥尔德林和尼尔·阿姆斯特朗踏上了月球。俄国人放弃了，这对于博尔曼来说是整件事的意义所在。所以他做了一件今天看起来很了不起的事。他辞职了。他放弃了许多孩子梦想的工作。
If you had stayed, could you have walked on the moon?
如果你留下，你可以走上月球吗？
Oh, yeah. I could have. Probably. I probably could have walked on the moon. Yeah.
噢，是的。我本可以。可能吧。我可能可以走上月球。是的。
Did you want to?
你想去吗？
No. Why? Look, the answer to your question-- I would have not accepted the risk involved to go pick up rocks. It doesn't mean that much to me.
不。为什么？看，你的问题的答案——我不会接受去捡石头所涉及的风险。那对我意义不大。
Somebody else wanted to do it. Let them take my place. I love my family more than anything in the world. I would have never subjected them to the dangers simply for me to be an explorer.
别人想做就去做吧。让他们取代我的位置。我爱我的家人胜过世上的一切。我永远不会仅仅为了让我成为探险家，就让他们置身于危险之中。
How often do you think of the Apollo 8 mission? Just when you're on your own, doing your normal stuff.
你多久会想起阿波罗8号任务？当你独自一人，做着日常工作的时候。
It never occurred in our lives much at all, really.
它在我们的生活中根本没出现过几次，真的。
I was looking up at the moon the other night, and it still feels crazy to me that you were there. If you do think back to it, is there a particular part that you tend to remember?
前几天晚上我抬头看月亮，你曾在那里让我觉得还是很不可思议。如果你回想起来，有什么特别的部分是你倾向于记住的吗？
The thing that reminds me, that I recall till the day I die, was the Earth, looking back at the Earth.
让我记住的，我到死都会记得的事情，是地球，回望地球。
I wouldn't say Borman hated space. He was just indifferent to it. Or put another way, he has a strong preference for the Earth.
我不会说博尔曼讨厌太空。他只是对它漠不关心。或者换句话说，他对比地球有强烈的偏好。
I've written a bunch of endings for this story. About yes, it's in our nature to explore. It's also in our nature to want to be home. But I'm very aware of the fact that so many historians and journalists and thinkers have tried to read particular meanings into that time that we went to the moon.
我写了很多关于这个故事的结尾。关于：是的，探索是我们的本性。想要待在家里也是我们的本性。但我非常清楚，许多历史学家、记者和思想家都试图解读出我们去月球那段时间的特殊意义。
I'm just going to end this the way the world's most uncomplicated man might-- the facts of the present, what he's doing now. It's as earthbound as it gets. Here it is. His wife, Susan, has Alzheimer's, for nine years now.
我只想以世界上最简单的人可能的方式来结束这个故事——当前的现实，他现在正在做的事情。这非常接地气。就是这样。他的妻子苏珊，患有阿尔茨海默症，已经九年了。
I'm with her every day, and she can't walk or talk or feed herself. So that's where I come in. So that's very, very difficult-- very. And that's it.
我每天都和她在一起，她不能走路、说话或自己吃饭。所以我来了。所以这非常、非常困难——非常。就这样。
Which is either the least romantic thing you can think of or just the opposite.
这要么是你能想到的最不浪漫的事情，要么恰恰相反。
David Kestenbaum. He's one of the producers of our show. The documentary he mentioned about Apollo 8 is called Earthrise. The film is opening this weekend in New York at the Maysles Documentary Center, New Yorkers, and will be released on the TV show, POV, and the New York Times' Op-Docs website in October.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。他是我们节目的制作人之一。他提到的关于阿波罗8号的纪录片叫《地出》。这部电影本周末在纽约的梅塞尔斯纪录片中心上映，纽约的朋友，并将于10月在电视节目《POV》以及《纽约时报》的Op-Docs网站上发布。
Coming up, when in doubt, when your life's out of whack, there's always Switzerland. Some pros and cons of that solution in a minute from WBEZ Chicago when our program continues.
接下来，当有疑问时，当你的生活失控时，总还有瑞士。稍后在来自芝加哥WBEZ的节目中，我们将讨论这个方案的一些利弊。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "The Not-So-Great Unknown." We have stories today of unromantic, unadventurous people in deeply adventurous situations.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目——“不那么伟大的未知”。我们今天的故事是关于不浪漫、不爱冒险的人身处极其冒险的情况。
We've arrived at Act 2 of our program, Act 2-- Traveling Violation.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕，第二幕——旅行违规。
Jared Marcelle knows a guy, a friend of his, who-- this very week that we're making this show-- is heading out into the unknown, embarking on the kind of trip that for most people would be a great adventure. And this guy is doing it for entirely practical reasons. Or anyway, that's how he sees it. He is sure this is the right choice, that it's what he needs to do. Jared, however-- he is not so sure.
杰瑞德·马塞尔认识一个家伙，他的朋友——就在我们制作这个节目的这一周——正要走向未知，踏上那场对大多数人来说将是一次伟大冒险的旅程。而这个家伙完全是出于实际原因才这么做的。或者说，他是这么看的。他确定这是正确的选择，这是他需要做的事。然而，杰瑞德——他不太确定。
Quick warning that there's a curse word in this story that is not beeped here on the podcast of the program. If you prefer a beeped version of our show-- maybe listening with kids-- it's at our website. Here's Jared.
快速警告一下，这个故事里有一个脏话，播客节目中没有消音。如果你更喜欢消音版——也许是和孩子一起听——请去我们的网站。这是杰瑞德。
Joel Wright and I are close. We grew up together in Crown Heights, in Brooklyn. Back then, Joel was a small and goofy kid.
乔尔·赖特和我关系很好。我们在布鲁克林的皇冠高地一起长大。那时候，乔尔是个瘦小又笨拙的孩子。
We got together recently, talking about those days. We were always trying to figure out how to make money.
我们最近聚在一起，谈起那些日子。我们总是试图找出怎么赚钱。
Making $0.50 stretch. You know, making $0.85 stretch. Taking care of each other, making sure we ate.
让50美分更有价值。你知道，让85美分更有价值。互相照顾，确保我们有饭吃。
Bro, I remember there were times where we would meet in front of my house or your building. And we would say, OK, I'm going go in and look for change I got. I'll come back with like $0.50, $0.75. You come back with whatever you have-- a dollar, $0.75. I looked for the change in the couch. You come back. And now we got to eat.
兄弟，我记得有几次我们会在我房子或你大楼前见面。我们会说，好吧，我要进去看看我有什么零钱。我回来时带大约50美分、75美分。你带回来不管有什么——一美元、75美分。我在沙发里找零钱。你回来。现在我们要吃东西了。
Yeah, I remember-- I was going to a pizza shop and splitting that pizza down the middle.
是的，我记得——我会去披萨店，把那个披萨对半分开。
We'd always divide stuff in half. One time, we only had enough to buy a single chicken wing. We split it down the middle. It was a rule. We had to make sure each other was fed.
我们总是把东西平分。有一次，我们只够买一只鸡翅。我们把它平分了。这是个规矩。我们必须确保对方吃饱。
Joel was an average student and didn't really excel at anything, except maybe video games. Love you, man, but it's true. I was more of a hustler, and always found new ways to get paid, like shoveling snow.
乔尔是个普通学生，除了电子游戏可能没什么擅长的。爱你，哥们，但这是真的。我更像个推销员，总是找到赚钱的新方法，比如铲雪。
Because I did it he gave it a try, but ultimately he was just too lazy to follow through. I ended up shoveling for him when he got tired. Joel meant well, but he just needed to find himself, find his thing.
因为我做了，他也试了试，但最终他太懒了，没坚持下去。当他累了时，我最后替他铲了雪。乔尔是好意，但他只是需要找到自我，找到他的东西。
And then it was like overnight he did. We'd always play basketball together, but he wasn't good. Then I went away to school for the ninth grade and when I came back, Joel stood about 6'5".
然后就像一夜之间，他找到了。我们总是聚在一起打篮球，但他不擅长。然后我去读九年级，回来时，乔尔已经有6英尺5英寸高了。
Frankly, I was jealous. And he'd become a local star. People were now calling him Air Jamaica-- he's Jamaican. Joel was now practicing twice a day-- at 6:30 AM before class and as well as after school ended. Basketball had changed him.
坦白说，我很嫉妒。他成了当地的明星。人们现在称他为“牙买加飞人”——他是牙买加人。乔尔现在每天练习两次——课前早上6:30，放学后也是。篮球改变了他。
Joel played all four years in college, and eventually the pros. He went undrafted but played in the NBA D League. That's the NBA's version of the minor leagues.
乔尔在大学打了四年，最终进入了职业赛。他没有被选中，但在NBA发展联盟打球。那是NBA的发展联盟，相当于小联盟。
Joel Wright, Number 15. One article called him the D league's most underrated player. In one game, he scored 41 points.
乔尔·赖特，15号。一篇文章称他是发展联盟被低估最多的球员。在一场比赛中，他得了41分。
Ahead to Covington. All alone-- right. He is now 18 for 18.
传球给卡温顿。孤身一人——右侧。他现在18投18中。
It didn't pay very much-- $13,000 a year, a penny to an NBA star. Then he got an offer to play overseas. The money was great. One team paid him $25,000 a month for two months.
工资不高——一年13,000美元，NBA明星的零头。然后他收到了去海外打球的邀请。钱很不错。一支球队给他一个月2.5万美元，为期两个月。
He asked me if I would go with him, all expenses paid. It was a foreign land and he wanted someone to make him feel comfortable. But I was trying to make my own life. I couldn't do that following him. He went to the Philippines.
他问我愿不愿意陪他去，所有费用全包。那是一个陌生的国度，他想找个人让他感到舒适。但我当时在试图建立自己的生活。我不能为了追随他而那么做。他去了菲律宾。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语讲话]
Also Malaysia and Saudi Arabia.
还有马来西亚和沙特阿拉伯。
You remember times where I was calling you from Saudi Arabia? Like, ah, damn me. I had goat, bro.
你还记得我从沙特阿拉伯给你打电话的时候吗？唉，该死。兄弟，我吃了山羊。
Like, goat-- I'm eating-- I'm Jamaican. So often time, I eat curry goat. But I never had the real goat, like-- you see what I'm saying? Bro, yo--
比如山羊——我正在吃——我是牙买加人。所以通常我吃咖喱山羊。但我从来没吃过真正的山羊，像——你知道我在说什么吗？兄弟，哟——
What's real goat?
什么是真正的山羊？
Yo, I had the whole goat. Like, I had the whole goat in front of me, bro. Like, the tongue, the eye, the teeth, everything. It was just weird over there.
哟，我面前有一整只山羊，兄弟。舌头、眼睛、牙齿，什么都有。那边真奇怪。
Sometimes in the middle of the game, you got to stop because it's praying time. But I like it though. The people is nice. It's genuine people, you know?
有时比赛中途，你得停下来，因为到了祈祷时间。但我喜欢这样。人们很好。他们是真诚的人，你懂吗？
Everyone on the team had to pray, even if they weren't Muslim?
队里的每个人都必须祈祷，即使他们不是穆斯林？
No, only basically, like, Saudis. When I went, I started praying with them. I started learning the first prayer.
不，基本上只有沙特人。我去的时候，也开始和他们一起祈祷了。我开始学习第一次祈祷。
I started studying, and it was very interesting. You know, because I got so equipped with the people over there, man. Like, I'm a people's guy. You know me well--
我开始钻研，这非常有意思。你知道，因为我融入了那里的人们，伙计。我是一个乐于助人的人。你很了解我——
OK, that's how he talks about it now. I remember that story a bit differently. And his time in Saudi Arabia was especially tough on him.
好吧，他现在是这么说的。但我对那个故事的记忆有点不同。他在沙特阿拉伯的那段时间对他来说特别艰难。
Joel was home sick. He'd call me almost every night, saying he missed his family. Eventually, he did come home the following March, and spent the summer playing in basketball tournaments as he prepared for his next job.
乔尔想家了。他几乎每天晚上都给我打电话，说想念家人。最终，他在次年3月回了家，夏天就在准备下一份工作的同时参加篮球锦标赛。
A team in Belgium was interested. The deal came just in time, as Joel's funds were low because he was too generous with his money, something I'd always warned him about. But he felt it was his job to help everyone.
比利时的一支球队感兴趣。合同来得正是时候，因为乔尔的资金很紧张，因为他对钱太大方了，这是我一直警告他的事。但他觉得帮助每个人是他的工作。
And this is when Joel really entered the great unknown. There's something I haven't told you about him, and it's something he didn't even know until he was in high school. Joel is not a US citizen. His mom brought him here illegally when he was little. He's one of the DACA kids.
这就是乔尔真正进入伟大未知的时候。关于他，有一件事我没告诉你，而且甚至在他上高中之前他自己都不知道。乔尔不是美国公民。他小时候，他妈妈非法把他带到了这里。他是DACA（童年入境暂缓遣返）的孩子之一。
Right now under DACA, people like him could stay here, work, and go to school. So Joel got the opportunity to play in Belgium, which he was going to take. But then on TV one night, he saw that President Trump was trying to cancel DACA. He talked to his lawyer, who said leaving the country now would be a bad idea. He might have a hard time getting back in again.
目前在DACA下，像他这样的人可以留在这里，工作和上学。所以乔尔有机会在比利时打球，他打算接受。但后来有一天晚上他在电视上看到特朗普总统试图取消DACA。他咨询了律师，律师说现在离开国家会是个坏主意。他可能很难再回来。
So it's like, you leave now, it's like you just leaving the country. You just leaving America and that's it. You see what I'm saying? Once you leave, it's nothing for you to come back. Nothing at all for you to come back.
所以就是说，你现在离开，就等于直接离开这个国家。你只是离开了美国，就这样。你明白我在说什么吗？一旦你离开，就没法再回来了。没有任何办法让你回来。
So that's when it got to me. That's when I took a step back. I'm like, yo, I'mma have to really evaluate this. And then that's when I got out the contract.
所以那时我动摇了。那时我退后了一步。我在想：哟，我得认真评估一下。然后我就解约了。
Joel told the Belgian team he wasn't coming, which ruined his reputation with them. His agent dropped him as a client. Joel ran out of money, slept on friend's couches and floors.
乔尔告诉比利时球队他不去了，这毁了他与他们的关系。他的经纪人放弃了他。乔尔花光了钱，睡在朋友的沙发和地板上。
He got irritable and stopped training for a bit. Everyone was asking why Air Jamaica is still home. It must have been because he couldn't get a job, right?
他变得暴躁，暂停了训练。每个人都在问为什么“牙买加飞人”还留在家里。那一定是因为他找不到工作，对吧？
Shame and embarrassment kept him from ever telling people he was out of money and living out of his suitcase. It kind of broke him. Here he went from being a made man to living at the mercy of others.
羞愧和尴尬让他没法告诉别人他没钱了，只能提着行李箱生活。这在某种程度上击垮了他。他从一个成功人士变成了一个仰人鼻息的人。
It had almost been two years since he played professionally, which can kill a career. Younger, fresher athletes are streamed into the talent pool every year. Then one day this spring, I got a call from him.
他已经快两年没打职业比赛了，这可能会毁掉一个职业生涯。每年都有更年轻、更有活力的运动员进入人才库。然后今年春天有一天，我接到了他的电话。
He'd signed a new contract. Joel was going to play for a team in Switzerland. It seemed like a terrible idea. The courts, for the moment, have kept DACA alive, but the government has stopped giving DACA recipients permission to travel abroad. So if he left, it was now totally unclear how he'd be able to get back in.
他签了一份新合同。乔尔要去瑞士的一支球队打球。这看起来是个糟糕的主意。法院目前虽然保留了DACA，但政府已经停止给DACA接收者出国旅行的许可。所以如果他离开，现在完全不清楚他要怎么回来。
I'm basically, in other words, taking my own deportation from my family, from my loved ones, from America, period. And I'm basically going to start a new life somewhere else, not knowing how I'll be able to get back in the country, not knowing if I'll ever see America again.
换句话说，我基本上是在让自己被驱逐出家人、爱人和美国。我基本上要到别的地方开始新生活，不知道怎么能回到这个国家，不知道是否还会再见到美国。
One Thursday night, I went to go see Joel play at a tournament at West 4th. An older guy called the game on a megaphone.
一个周四晚上，我去西四街看乔尔打球。一个老家伙拿着扩音器喊话。
Gentleman, do not get hurt. Gentleman, do not get hurt.
先生们，不要受伤。先生们，不要受伤。
This is a game with a bunch of guys who make a living playing basketball. I hadn't seen Joel play in a while.
这是一场有一堆以打球为生的人参加的比赛。我很久没看乔尔打球了。
How you feel right now?
你现在感觉如何？
Good as shit. I just finished a great game.
好极了。我刚打完一场精彩的比赛。
He finished the game with about 25 points, but he looked a little rusty. At least, to me he did. He's still working his way back, and I worry what if he has a bad season? The Swiss team has only guaranteed him a contract for a year.
他最后得了大约25分，但他看起来有点生疏。至少对我来说是这样。他还在找状态，我担心如果他赛季表现不好怎么办？瑞士球队只保证了一年的合同。
If he gets hurt, then what? They could drop him. Then where would he be? He probably can't come home.
如果他受伤了怎么办？他们可能让他走人。那时他会在哪儿？他可能回不了家。
But whenever we talk about this, he doesn't want to hear it. He stands by his decision.
但每当我们谈起这个，他都不想听。他坚持自己的决定。
You can't-- I can't name 10 people on my finger that would make that decision, but I'm happy with my decision. I'm comfortable with my decision.
你无法——我数不出十个人会做出那个决定，但我对我的决定很开心。我对我的决定感到坦然。
But do you understand why I'm not that comfortable with it?
但你明白为什么我对它不那么坦然吗？
Yeah-- of course, I understand why you're not that comfortable with it. I mean, you, my friends, my loved one, my mom, nothing-- nobody is comfortable with it. But it comes to a time in your life when you've got to make important decisions for the things you love. You've got to make sacrifices for the things you love. And I'm just ready to sacrifice.
是的——我当然明白为什么你不那么坦然。我的意思是，你、我的朋友、我的爱人、我妈，没人对它感到坦然。但当你人生到了某个时刻，你必须为你爱的东西做出重要的决定。你必须为你爱的东西做出牺牲。而我已经准备好牺牲了。
Like, what's the worst case scenario? I think we both know the worst case scenario, though-- you getting hurt. And we don't know if they'll stick by you, right?
比如，最坏的情况是什么？我想我们都知道最坏的情况，就是你受伤了。我们不知道他们是否会支持你，对吧？
Like, we don't know if this team will stand by you and keep you around. Like, they're shipping Americans overseas like this, like a supermarket. You just buy another one.
我们不知道这支球队是否会支持你并留住你。他们像超市一样把美国人运往海外。你只是再买一个新的。
I'm not thinking about getting hurt. That's never been on my mind.
我没在想受伤的事。那从来没在我脑子里出现过。
No, of course, you're not thinking about it. But, like, these are possibilities that I feel like we have to talk about.
不，你当然没在想。但是，这些可能性我觉得我们必须谈谈。
This is possibility that's not on my mind. Because if I put that possibility in my mind, it's like I'm putting that energy in the air. That's not the energy I want in the air. That's not the vibe I want to put out in the atmosphere.
这种可能性没在我脑子里。因为如果我把这种可能性放在脑子里，就好像我把那种能量释放到空气中。那不是我想释放到空气中的能量。那不是我想释放到大气中的氛围。
I don't want to put that, because the stake is so big for me. That can't be on my mind. Being hurt can't be on my mind.
我不想那样，因为这对我来说赌注太大了。那不能在我脑子里。受伤这件事不能在我脑子里。
In sports, this is a great mentality to have. Losing isn't an option. This kind of thing is going to help him make game winning shots.
在体育运动中，这是一种很棒的心态。失败不是选项。这种心态会帮他投进制胜球。
But in life, it seems like a dangerous way to live. I reminded him that last time he went abroad, it was tough on him, and he was only gone eight months. This time, it could be years.
但在生活中，这似乎是一种危险的生活方式。我提醒他上次去海外对他来说很艰难，而且他只待了八个月。这一次，可能是几年。
You know, this time I'm mentally prepared. Like, I'm mentally ready to fit in and to know what I'm moving towards.
你知道，这次我心理上做好了准备。我心理上准备好适应，并且知道我正在走向何方。
But my thing is this though, because you definitely weren't happy. You were very homesick. Like, what could have really happened in the past two years that could have you not only ready to leave, but you're leaving under the understanding that coming back here is going to be damn near-- I'm not going to say damn near impossible, but it's going to be tough.
但我的意思是，你肯定当时并不快乐。你非常想家。过去两年究竟发生了什么，能让你不仅准备离开，而且是在明白回来几乎——我不想说几乎不可能，但会非常艰难的情况下离开的。
Two words-- ambition and pride. For the past two years, I felt like I haven't had control over anything, and I think that's what drove me to the worst. I feel like that's what put me in depression stage. I feel like that's what did a lot of those things to me, because I just felt like I was out of control of everything, out of my life. I felt like everything was wild.
两个词——雄心和骄傲。过去两年，我觉得我对任何事都没有控制权，我认为这把我推向了最糟的境地。我觉得正是它把我推向了抑郁阶段。我觉得这正是它对我造成的影响，因为我觉得我对自己的一切失去了控制。我觉得一切都乱套了。
So that makes it much easier. It makes it much easier to make decisions like that, when you deal with certain stuff. And I know I've got on the phone with you millions of time, and I express all of this stuff to you, man. Pride is a crazy thing.
所以这让决定变得容易多了。当你经历某些事时，做出这样的决定就容易多了。我知道我曾和你打过无数次电话，我向你表达过这一切，伙计。骄傲真是个疯狂的东西。
I'm scared for you. That's all I'm saying.
我为你害怕。我只想说这些。
Yeah. Me scared for me too. My mom is scared for me. Everybody's scared for me. But is scared then covering what I've got to take care of. 28 years old. What's being scared going to do to me now?
是的。我也为自己害怕。我妈也为我害怕。每个人都为我害怕。但害怕能解决我必须处理的事情吗？28岁了。害怕现在对我有什么用？
I get it. Joel has a lot of people like me in his life, telling him this is a bad idea. But we're not offering him anything that seems better.
我明白了。乔尔生命中有很多人像我一样，告诉他这是个坏主意。但我们没提供任何看起来更好的方案。
If it were me, I'd get a 9 to 5 job, settle into the world. But Joel doesn't want an ordinary life. His approach to dealing with adversity is to just work even harder at the thing he's good at. And that's basketball. He wants to be a basketball player again.
如果是我，我会找份朝九晚五的工作，安顿下来。但乔尔不想过普通生活。他面对逆境的方式就是在他擅长的事情上更加努力。那就是篮球。他想再次成为篮球运动员。
He just wants these last two years to be over. The risk is too great for me to cosign this move, but maybe that's my problem. Maybe in some ways I've subconsciously become a pillar of uniformity.
他只是想让过去这两年结束。风险太大，我无法支持这个举动，但也许那是我的问题。也许在某些方面，我下意识地成了循规蹈矩的支柱。
I asked him what he knows about Switzerland. And he said he doesn't know anything. I told him to at least Google the weather. I know he doesn't like the cold.
我问他对瑞士了解多少。他说他什么都不知道。我告诉他至少去查查天气。我知道他不喜欢寒冷。
Joel's flight was scheduled for Thursday-- yesterday. We spent the day together. He went to the barbershop and got a haircut, then visited his mom at the restaurant she works at. She was in the kitchen cooking. She said a little prayer for him.
乔尔的航班定在周四——昨天。我们一起度过了一天。他去理发店理了发，然后探望了在他工作的餐厅的妈妈。她正在厨房做饭。她为他做了个小祈祷。
I'm going to miss you, man. I pray everything you do may prosperous and success. In the name of the Father, and the Son, and his Holy Spirit to guide you and protect you upon your journey.
我会想你的，伙计。我祈祷你所做的一切都能繁荣成功。以圣父、圣子、圣灵之名指引并保护你的旅程。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
And guide you upon your--
并指引你走上——
On this sacrifice.
这次牺牲。
It's a journey, OK?
这是一段旅程，好吗？
It's a marathon, not a sprint.
这是马拉松，不是短跑。
American and a sprint?
美国和短跑？
It's a marathon, not a sprint.
这是马拉松，不是短跑。
Oh.
哦。
It's not a sprint. It's no rush.
这不是短跑。不着急。
After that we drove to the airport and said goodbye.
之后我们开车去机场，告别了。
If you happy, I'm happy. Not really, but yeah.
如果你快乐，我就快乐。不全是，但好吧。
All right, man.
好吧，伙计。
My dog, B.
我的老铁。
All right, bro.
好吧，兄弟。
Air Jamaica has left the building. I just hope he can come back.
“牙买加飞人”已经离开了。我只希望他能回来。
Jared Marcelle lives in New York.
杰瑞德·马塞尔住在纽约。
Act 3-- A Fly on the Call. So there are all kinds of experiences that people avoid because they are just too far out there-- too daring, taboo. This next story is a work of fiction about somebody who gets up the nerve, and tries something that he's always wondered about.
第三幕——通话中的苍蝇。人们会回避各种各样的体验，因为它们太离谱——太大胆、禁忌。接下来的故事是一部关于某人鼓起勇气，尝试他一直好奇的事情的虚构作品。
Quick warning that this story has nothing explicit in it at all, but it refers to some grown up activities that probably aren't right for kids to hear about, and won't make much sense to lots of them anyway. This piece of fiction was written by Neil Drumming. It's read for us by an actor, Dorian Missick.
快速警告一下，这个故事里没有任何露骨内容，但它提到了一些成年人的活动，可能不适合孩子听，无论如何他们也听不懂。这部虚构作品由尼尔·德拉明编写。由演员多里安·米西克为我们朗读。
Cassie answered the phone all sharp and bothered-- "Hello?"-- like she wasn't expecting anyone, which technically I'm not anyone to her. "You're late," she said. That I was, about two minutes late. She wasn't usually this particular though.
凯西尖锐且困扰地接了电话——“喂？”——好像她没期待任何人，而技术上讲，我对她来说确实不算任何人。“你迟到了，”她说。我确实迟到了，大约两分钟。她通常没这么讲究。
"Yes, mistress. I'm sorry, mistress." I usually don't have much to say. Cassie and I have a routine. OK, let me back up for a minute.
“是的，女主人。对不起，女主人。”我通常没什么可说的。凯西和我有个常规。好吧，让我倒退一下。
A few months ago, I decided to go see a dominatrix. Like, a real one, at a dungeon and everything. It was something I'd always fantasized about and I'd just gotten out of a relationship, so I didn't have to try to hide it from anyone.
几个月前，我决定去见一位女王（Dominatrix）。那种真正的女王，在地牢里，应有尽有。那是我一直幻想的事，我刚结束一段关系，所以不需要对任何人隐瞒。
I got excited, left the office two hours early on a Tuesday, took the train to this place I had heard about in midtown. Inside, it wasn't what I was expecting, but it was a lot. The smell of leftover sweat on the leather. Muffled sound of some poor bastard down the hall getting berated. The paperwork, like, literally checking boxes next to taboo desires I don't actually have-- foot fetish, medical play, jeez.
我很兴奋，周二提前两小时离开办公室，坐火车去了我在市中心听说过的地方。进去后，它不是我期待的那样，但确实令人震撼。皮革上残留汗水的味道。走廊下那个可怜虫被训斥的沉闷声音。文书工作，像是真的在勾选我并没有的禁忌欲望——足控、医疗玩法，天哪。
I passed a couple other customers. White dudes under the dim, red lights. They looked me up and down like I couldn't possibly be into this stuff too. Huh, even here. They were was sort of right though.
我经过了其他几个顾客。红灯昏暗下的白人男士。他们打量着我，好像我不可能是来这种地方的人。哈，即使在这里也是如此。但他们也没错。
I ended up in a room, blindfolded, with my hands cuffed behind the back. This woman with a vaguely European name and accent shut the thick wooden doors and started in with the humiliation, barking at me to kneel. I paid for the session up front, so I was trying to commit-- to submit, I should say.
我最后进了一个房间，蒙着眼，双手被拷在背后。这个有着欧洲姓名和口音的女人关上厚重的木门，开始羞辱，大声命令我跪下。我预付了费用，所以我尽量投入——或者说，尽量顺从。
I was still too much in my head, involuntarily dissecting the fantasy piece by piece. Sure, the handcuffs were real enough, but nothing else was. This woman couldn't possibly be this angry. I mean, I just got here.
我脑子里还是想得太多，不由自主地把幻想拆解成一片片。当然，手铐确实是真的，但除此之外都不是。这个女人不可能真的这么生气。我的意思是，我刚到。
She just got me down on my knees when there was a knock at the door. The mistress was called out into the hallway to deal with some dungeon-related clerical issue. So she left me there-- no explanation, no sorry, I'll be right back.
她刚让我跪下，门就响了。女主人被叫到走廊处理一些和地牢相关的文书问题。所以她把我丢在那里——没有解释，没有道歉，没说我马上回来。
I wasn't alone. She was right outside, squabbling with the house mistress. But the point is she wasn't paying attention to me. I was there, but I wasn't considered important enough to be considered. It felt somehow great.
我没孤单。她就在门外，和当家女主人争吵。但重点是她没在注意我。我在那里，但我没被认为重要到需要被关注。那种感觉竟然很好。
I felt like it didn't matter what I had to say or what I did next. She come back when she decided to come back and that was it. I don't know if that makes sense, but it was like being reminded that the world would just keep going on without me, that I was nothing, that I was weightless.
我觉得无论我下一句说什么或做什么都不重要了。她想回来时就会回来，就这样。我不知道这是否有意义，但这就像被提醒：世界没有我也会继续运转，我什么都不是，我没有重量。
I mean, it might sound dark to some people. But I don't know, to me, it just felt like the truth. I was into it. That was it, my pervert origin story. No gamma radiation, no meteor shower, just me in a room, powerless and forgotten.
我的意思是，这对某些人听起来可能很黑暗。但我不知道，对我来说，这感觉像是真相。我沉迷于此。就这样，我的变态起源故事。没有伽马辐射，没有流星雨，只有我在房间里，无力且被遗忘。
And just like anything else that feels good to you and seems weird to other people, there's a whole cottage industry dedicated to it. After only a minimal amount of research on the topics of abandonment fetish and neglect fantasy, I found myself nervously browsing online for phone sex workers who would gladly ignore me for an hourly rate.
就像任何对你感觉很好但对别人看起来很奇怪的事物一样，有一个完整的产业致力于此。在对放弃迷恋和忽视幻想的主题进行最少量的研究后，我发现自己正紧张地在网上浏览那些乐于按小时收费来忽略我的电话性服务者。
Mistress Cassie wasn't the first woman I called for this service, but she was the one who figured me out. With the others, I'd call up and they'd make a big ruckus of running a hot bath, unwrapping some expensive gift chosen from an Amazon wish list by a wealthy admirer. I'd hear them cooing about new lingerie, clomping around their apartments in high heels.
女主人凯西不是我为此服务打给的第一个女人，但她是那个看穿我的人。给其他人打电话时，她们会大张旗鼓地假装在放热水澡，拆开富有崇拜者在亚马逊愿望清单里选的昂贵礼物。我会听到她们对着新内衣咕哝，穿着高跟鞋在公寓里走来走去。
And that was intended to be my cue to, I guess, get off somehow? For the record, it's not sexual like that for me. For me, it's a mental thing.
那是想作为我的 cue（暗示）让我，我猜，怎么着？声明一下，对我来说不是那种性事。对我来说，那是心理上的。
With Cassie, there was no, "god, it's so warm in here," or, "I got to get out of these wet clothes," exaggerated bullshit. She kept it 100% real. Most days, I'd just focus on the sound of her fingernails dragging against her laptop as she lazily surfed the web.
在凯西这里，没有那种“天哪，这里好暖和”或者“我得脱掉湿衣服”的夸张废话。她保持100%真实。大多数日子，我只是专注于她指甲划过笔记本电脑的声音，因为她正慵懒地在网上冲浪。
Sometimes she watched Netflix, smoked weed until she fell asleep, and I'd sit silently through whole episodes of Black Mirror and Archer with no responsibility other than to think about her-- what she might be wearing, was she dreaming-- knowing that I had absolutely no impact on any of it. I was a nonevent in her uneventful life.
有时她看网飞，抽大麻直到睡着，我会静静地看完一整集《黑镜》和《弓箭手》，除了想她——她可能穿什么，她在做梦吗——没有责任。我知道我对这一切绝对没有影响。我是她平淡生活中平淡无奇的一部分。
When I was on the phone with Cassie, I could feel my muscles relax. The demands of my own existence faded away. My will disappeared into the silence between us. I breathe easier.
当我和凯西打电话时，我能感觉到肌肉放松。我自身存在的索取逐渐消失。我的意志消融在我们之间的沉默中。我呼吸得更顺畅了。
It's funny. I spent my whole life working twice as hard to show the next man that I'm at it, only to reach a place where I was happy being utterly beside the point. Progress is weird.
很有趣。我一生都在努力工作，向别人展示我有多上进，结果却到达了一个我愿意彻底无足轻重的地步。进步很奇怪。
Anyway, like I said, today with Cassie was different. She was agitated from the moment she got on the line. "What exactly is it that you want to hear from me?" she asked bluntly and loud. I was used to Cassie being herself, but this was more.
无论如何，就像我说的，今天和凯西的情况不同。她从接通线路的那一刻起就很烦躁。“你到底想从我这里听到什么？”她直白而大声地问。我习惯凯西做她自己，但这超出了惯例。
"Well," she snapped, "What do you want me to say?" I froze. I didn't know how to respond. And then someone else spoke, someone else in the room with Cassie that I hadn't realized was there, some guy.
“好吧，”她厉声说，“你想要我说什么？”我僵住了。我不知道该如何回应。然后有别人说话了，在凯西房间里我没意识到还有别人，是个男的。
I almost laughed into the phone. I should have recognized the question right away. "What do you want me to say?"
我差点对着电话笑出声。我应该马上认出那个问题的。“你想要我说什么？”
I asked somebody the same thing in the same tone less than a year ago, and again six or seven months before that. "What do you want me to say?" It's never actually a question, is it?
不到一年前，我用同样的语气问过别人同样的问题，在那之前的六七个月前也问过。 “你想要我说什么？”那从来不是一个问题，不是吗？
Cassie had apparently answered my call while in the middle of a fight with some guy and decided to take it anyway, because that's our deal. Whatever happens, I listen. And so I heard the guy say that he thought she was being stubborn, and that was obviously something they needed to talk about.
凯西显然是在和某个男的吵架中间接了我的电话，并决定无论如何都接了，因为那是我们的约定。无论发生什么，我都听着。所以我听到那个男人说他觉得她太顽固了，这显然是他们需要谈谈的事。
She insisted that they were talking. They were talking right now. There was a long pause. And then he said her name, her real name. And I thought to myself, that doesn't sound right. I prefer Cassie.
她坚持说他们在谈。他们现在就在谈。长久的沉默。然后他说出了她的名字，她的真名。我心想，那听起来不对。我更喜欢凯西。
Cassie let the phone hang by her side, and I felt like a kid trying to make sense of his parents arguing. But the gist of the conversation was that Cassie was planning to go away this weekend with some friends. These friends included an ex-boyfriend of hers. Cassie insisted she had no intentions of hooking up with him, but he was still an important part of her life.
凯西让电话挂在身边，我觉得自己像个试图理解父母争吵的孩子。但谈话的要点是凯西计划这周末和朋友去远足。这些朋友包括她的前男友。凯西坚持说她没打算和他勾搭，但他仍然是她生命中重要的一部分。
The guy was not at all OK with this plan. There was some pleading and cross-talking and a lot of shouting. And at one point, a door slammed. And I stood up, alone in my own apartment.
那个男人对这个计划一点也不满意。有一些哀求和互相插话，还有很多尖叫。有一次，门砰地关上了。我站起来，孤零零地呆在自己的公寓里。
And then it was over. "Hello?" It was Cassie, alone, in her apartment. And this time, she was definitely talking to me.
然后结束了。“喂？”是凯西，一个人，在她的公寓里。这次，她肯定是在和我说话。
"Did you hear all of that?" she asked. Her voice was low and hoarse. She'd been crying. "Yeah," I said. "Are you OK?"
“你听到这一切了吗？”她问。她的声音低沉沙哑。她在哭。“听到了，”我说。“你还好吗？”
"Let me ask you something," she said, taking one of those deep, shaky breaths. "If you love someone and you know they love you, no question, wouldn't you just trust them?" "Of course," I said, because that's the answer I would have wanted to hear.
“让我问你件事，”她说，深吸了一口气。“如果你爱某人，你也知道他们爱你，毫无疑问，你难道不应该信任他们吗？”“当然，”我说，因为那是我想要听到的答案。
"Are you just saying that to get me to stop crying?" she asked. I suddenly became aware of all the heavy things in my apartment-- the furniture, the TV, the desk stacked with bills, and the phone in my hand with Cassie on the other end. It was exhilarating feeling her there, closer, more real than she had ever been to me before. It was also kind of freaking me out.
“你只是为了让我停止哭泣才这么说的吗？”她问。我突然意识到我公寓里所有沉重的东西——家具、电视、堆满账单的书桌，以及手里握着的手机，另一端是凯西。感觉到她在那里、更近、比以往任何时候都真实，这令人振奋。这也让我有点恐慌。
"That's sweet," she said. "You could have hung up a long time ago." "Don't worry about it," I said. "I'm not giving you a refund," she said.
“那真甜，”她说。“你本来可以很久之前就挂断的。”“别担心，”我说。“我不会给你退款的，”她说。
I had to laugh. We talked for another 20, 25 minutes after that. And I mean, we did actually talk.
我忍不住笑了。在那之后我们又谈了20、25分钟。我的意思是，我们确实在谈。
Turns out, Cassie and I have a lot in common. Both from Jersey, both like house music, think that Black Mirror is overrated. She was funny. I hadn't thought of her as funny. She says she had that trip coming up, and then a doctor's appointment, and then some thing at her kid's school-- something else we also had common-- but that she'd be around in the middle of next week for another session.
结果发现，凯西和我有很多共同点。都来自新泽西，都喜欢浩室音乐，都觉得《黑镜》被高估了。她很有趣。我没想过她会很有趣。她说她那次旅行快到了，还有医生的预约，还有她孩子学校的事——我们还有其他的共同点——但她在下周中期有时间进行另一次对话。
After we hung up, I sat down at my desk, went online, and found Cassie's Amazon wish list. I picked out something tasteful-- sexy but not too provocative. And I sent it to Cassie, two day delivery. The next week, I booked a session with someone else, someone I didn't know.
挂断电话后，我坐在书桌前，上网找到了凯西的亚马逊愿望清单。我选了件有品位的——性感但不至于太挑衅。我寄给了凯西，两天送达。下周，我订了别人的对话，我不认识的人。
Dorian Missick reading a short story by one of our producers, Neil Drumming. The two of them, by the way, made a feature film a few years back called Big Words. Neil wrote and directed, Dorian starred. It's on iTunes and Amazon Prime.
多里安·米西克朗读了我们制片人之一尼尔·德拉明的短篇小说。顺便提一下，他们俩几年前合作了一部剧情片《大词》。尼尔编剧兼导演，多里安主演。在iTunes和亚马逊Prime上能看到。
So we close out our show today with this last story, a true story of an unadventurous explorer. The rapper Aesop Rock grew up in New York and lived in cities most of his life. And a few years ago, he decided he was going to pack up his gear and moved to the country into an actual barn to work on music. So there he is, writing lyrics and making beats in the middle of nowhere, surrounded by unfamiliar stuff, including wildlife. And he has thoughts about it.
今天我们以最后一个故事结束我们的节目，一个不爱冒险的探险家的真实故事。说唱歌手伊索普·洛克在纽约长大，大部分生活在城市里。几年前，他决定收拾装备搬到乡下一个真正的谷仓里创作音乐。所以他就坐在那儿，在偏僻的地方写歌词做节拍，被不熟悉的东西包围，包括野生动物。他对此有自己的想法。
[MUSIC - "RABIES" BY AESOP ROCK]
[音乐 - 伊索普·洛克的《狂犬病》]
(RAPPING) Hey. Warm cider, barn full of spiders. Orange moon, starry night, particle exciters in a pageant rivaled only by the origin of fire. Now add an organism from alternative environs.
（说唱）嘿。温苹果酒，谷仓全是蜘蛛。橙色月亮，星光之夜，粒子激发器，在只因火的起源而竞争的盛会中。现在加上来自替代环境的有机体。
A dozen pair of cartoon eyes in the thicket to see a neophyte get sliced into ribbons. I'm here to pick lice off each other and assimilate, duck a suit, troubleshoot his moody user interface. True and sucker-proof, grew to fully disengage.
灌木丛中一打卡通眼睛，看着一个新手被切成条。我在这儿清理彼此的虱子并同化，躲开西装，调试他喜怒无常的用户界面。真实且防骗，长到完全脱离。
Float his only vanishing point away from the picture plane. Go to where the radio trails off and people catch rabies on the way to their mailbox. Under a sideways rain cornering the brier, still pull a broad sword from a hoarded synthesizer.
把属于他的唯一消失点从画面平面移走。去广播信号微弱的地方，人们在去邮箱的路上感染狂犬病。在侧向的雨中包围荆棘，仍然从囤积的合成器中拔出阔剑。
Nap in a hole in a tree. Cat leaving voles at my feet. Talking Master P, memory foam, everything. Jettison the rest and roulette us a new trajectory. Spinal Tap 11, tapping resin out the evergreen.
在树洞里小睡。猫在我的脚边留下田鼠。谈论Master P，记忆泡沫，一切。抛弃其余的，为我们转出一条新轨道。 Spinal Tap 11，从常青树中敲出树脂。
Designated dark horse, headless independently. Sidewalks end with ponds and frog eggs. Buried bones, and his very own blurry Sasquatch vids.
指定的黑马，无头独立。人行道尽头是池塘和蛙卵。埋藏的骨头，还有他自己模糊的萨斯科奇视频。
Led like field ants to a hot lens. 8 o'clock kittens vs. cobwebs-- fight! Maps won't work here.
像田蚁一样被引向热透镜。8点的猫咪对阵蜘蛛网——打吧！地图在这里不管用。
Aesop Rock from the album, The Impossible Kid.
伊索普·洛克，来自专辑《不可能的孩子》。
Well, our program was produced today by Neil Drumming. People who helped make our program today-- Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Whitney Dangerfield, Jared Floyd, David Kestenbaum, Anna Martin, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
好吧，我们的节目今天由尼尔·德拉明制作。今天协助完成节目的有——埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、杰瑞德·弗洛伊德、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、安娜·马丁、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、娜迪亚·雷曼、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的主编是苏珊·伯顿。
Special thanks today to Brent Sayers and Charlotte Taillor. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
特别感谢今天的布伦特·赛耶斯和夏洛特·泰勒。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600集的存档节目。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, we were watching The Matrix, and I look over at him, and he's cheering for the robots! For the robots! He explains to me later--
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我们当时在看《黑客帝国》，我转头看他，他竟然在为机器人欢呼！为机器人欢呼！他后来向我解释说——
I think we're just very different people.
我想我们确实是两类不同的人。
I'm Ira Glass. Be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "RABIES" BY AESOP ROCK]
[音乐 - 伊索普·洛克的《狂犬病》]